así
la ventaja de este diagrama es que como
representa todas las opciones que tienes
podemos simplemente agregar más y más y
más opciones por abajo las 10 que si
tenemos dos cabezas tres cuerpos y tres
tipos de brazos
el diagrama se va a ver así
que nos da un total de 2 por 3 por 3 o
sea 18 distintas combinaciones
a estos diagramas a veces se les llama
diagramas de árbol porque si los
volteamos parecen árboles y este
diagrama nos ayuda a entender que
simplemente tenemos que multiplicar el
número de cada tipo de parte así es que
si sólo nos interesa saber cuántas
combinaciones se necesitan ya no
necesitamos el diagrama y el número de
combinaciones se hace grande muy rápido
por ejemplo si tuviéramos cinco cabezas
seis cuerpos y siete brazos y digamos
ocho tipos distintos de ruedas en
nuestros robots tendríamos que construir
cinco más 67 más 8 osea 26 tipos
distintos de objetos pero con estas
partes podríamos construir 5 por 6 por 7
por 8 osea 1.680 distintos robots
como hay tantas combinaciones posibles
es muy fácil emocionarse y alojarse un
poquito y construir una enorme multitud
de robots
aunque una gran multitud de robots puede
hacer que una película se vuelva más
emocionante tenemos que tomar en cuenta
que entre más robots haya los animadores
van a tener que animar a más robots y
hay una mayor cantidad de robots con los
que tienen que lidiar la computadora así
es que siempre tratamos de lograr
nuestras metas artísticas de la forma
más eficiente posible ahora es momento
de ponerte a trabajar a ti tu trabajo en
este ejercicio interactivo es asegurarte
de que tanto el director como el
productor estén contentos necesitas una
gran variedad de robots para que haya
mucho interés visual y el director esté
muy contento con tu trabajo pero también
necesitas mantener un bajo precio para
que el productor también esté contento
con tu trabajo aquí se muestra el precio
de cada parte selecciona un subconjunto
de cabezas cuerpos y brazos de tal forma
que si los combinamos de todas las
formas posibles obtengamos exactamente
12 robots
y el precio de todas las partes debe de
ser menor a 300 por cierto el director y
productor estarán aquí en 10 minutos
para revisar tu trabajo
yo sé que tú puedes con esto